Aquí tenemos este círculo llamado O por el
punto en su centro y tenemos el segmento OD,
y nos dicen que el segmento OD es el radio
del círculo O. Bien, además nos dicen que el
segmento OD es perpendicular a esta cuerda AC
o al segmento AC, y lo que queremos demostrar
es que el segmento OD biseca AC. Otra forma de
pensarlo es que interseca AC en su punto medio,
así que pausa el video e intenta encontrar
esta demostración. Bien, vamos a trabajar
juntos. La forma en la que vamos a hacerlo
es estableciendo dos triángulos congruentes,
vamos a dibujar estos triángulos. Dibujemos un
radio que vaya de O a C y otro que vaya de A a O.
Ahora, sabemos que la longitud de AO es igual a
la longitud de OC porque AO y OC son radios. En
un círculo la longitud de los radios no cambia,
así que podemos marcarlos de esta manera.
Además sabemos que OM va a ser congruente
consigo mismo, ya que es un lado en ambos
triángulos, vamos a escribirlo: OM ≅ OM, esto
es reflexividad, cumple la propiedad reflexiva,
obviamente es igual a sí mismo es congruente
consigo mismo, ya lo tenemos. Y ahora tenemos
dos triángulos rectángulos. ¿Cómo sabemos
que son rectángulos? Bueno, nos dicen:
el segmento OD ⊥ AC, es parte de la hipótesis que
nos dan. Ahora bien, si tenemos dos triángulos
que tienen dos pares de lados congruentes,
esto no es suficiente para establecer que
los triángulos son congruentes; sin embargo, si
estamos trabajando con dos triángulos rectángulos,
entonces sí es suficiente. Hay dos formas de
pensarlo. Podemos pensar en el criterio RLH,
donde si tienes dos triángulos rectángulos y
tienes que un par de sus lados son congruentes
y sus hipotenusas son congruentes, entonces los
dos triángulos rectángulos son congruentes. La
otra forma de pensarlo, que requiere un poco de
sentido común, es usar el Teorema de Pitágoras:
si conocemos dos lados de un triángulo rectángulo,
lo que nos dice el Teorema de Pitágoras es
que podemos determinar el lado faltante.
Entonces, vamos a utilizar el criterio RLH,
pero con el Teorema de Pitágoras también podríamos
establecer que AM es congruente con MC. Déjame
escribirlo de esta forma: el Δ AMO ≅ Δ CMO por el
criterio RLH, y si los triángulos son congruentes,
entonces los lados correspondientes deben serlo.
Por lo tanto, sabemos que el segmento AM ≅ CM,
entonces estos segmentos tendrán la misma
medida, y si tienen la misma medida, acabamos
de demostrar que M es el punto medio de AC, o
que OD biseca AC. Entonces, vamos a escribirlo,
por lo tanto: OD biseca AC, el segmento OD
biseca al segmento AC, y hemos terminado.